Війна в Україні вперше безпосередньо зачепила країну-члена НАТО.
Від польського селища Пшеводув близько п'яти кілометрів
до українського кордону. За 10 кілометрів проходить лінія,
якою Україна експортувала електроенергію до Польщі
- до російських атак по енергосистемі.
Напередодні ракета влучила у місцеві зерносушарки.
Двоє людей загинули.
Я побігла до вікна, вибух пролунав недалеко,
метрів за сто. Я побачила величезну хмару чорного страшного диму.
Якщо не помиляюся, ще бачила вогонь,
скоріш за все загорілися лінії електропередач.
У вечірньому зверненні у вівторок Володимир Зеленський
назвав інцидент "суттєвою ескалацією",
закликав НАТО до дій і наголосив,
що по Польщі вдарили російські ракети.
Водночас і польський президент Анджей Дуда,
і генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг наступного дня заявили,
що ознак цілеспрямованого обстрілу Польщі Росією немає.
Розслідування інциденту триває.
Нам варто дочекатися висновків.
Але у нас немає ознак того, що це результат навмисної атаки.
Також немає ознак того, що Росія готується до наступальних дій проти НАТО.
За даними попереднього аналізу, інцидент був спровокований ракетою
української ППО, яка захищала українську територію
від російського ракетного обстрілу.
Дозвольте наголосити: це не вина України.
Речник Повітряних сил України Юрій Ігнат
у коментарі DW закликав дочекатися результатів
розслідування й розглянути різні версії.
На його думку, якщо ракету запустили з Росії,
то цей удар не міг бути випадковим,
адже РФ била напередодні досить точними ракетами.
Юрій Ігнат не виключає, що теоретично влучити
могла й ракета української ППО.
Зрозуміло, що може бути балістична траєкторія,
різні можуть бути речі - це техніка,
техніка не нова, може бути й таке.
Але ракета зенітна, якщо втрачає ціль, С-300 чи Бук М-1,
у неї передбачений механізм самоліквідації.
Це теж треба розуміти.
Деякі українські експерти зазначають, що українська влада
поспішила заявити, що ракета прилетіла в Польщу з Росії.
Політолог Ігор Чаленко так не вважає.
На його думку, Володимир Зеленський заявляв про приліт
російської ракети після консультацій з військовими.
Усю правду дізнаються наші союзники,
але за зачиненими дверима.
Тому що ми розуміємо, якщо офіційно США або інші країни блоку НАТО
зараз напряму заявлять, що це був збройний напад РФ,
то звісно постане питання загалом єдності позиції всередині блоку НАТО.
А ми бачимо такі країни як Туреччина, Угорщина.
Тому я думаю, що поки немає цієї єдності всередині блоку,
в публічній сфері не будуть поспішати однозначно казати,
що це атака РФ. Набагато легше це дійсно
списати нібито це робота української ППО.
Поки ж західні союзники єдині в тому,
що ракета б не залетіла на територію НАТО,
якби не війна Росії проти України.
Про це заявили у Великобританії, Нідерландах, Німеччині.
Звідки б не був завданий удар по Польщі,
винна в цьому Росія - певен і аналітик Макс Бергманн.
Я думаю, незважаючи ні на що, Росія нестиме відповідальність.
Росія обстрілює українську територію крилатими ракетами.
І якщо українська протиповітряна оборона дійсно влучила
не туди, як стверджують росіяни, що, на мою думку,
не зовсім вірогідно, але якщо це так,
то все одно Росія несе відповідальність,
тому що вона атакує іншу країну
і запускає ракети по суверенній державі.
На думку британського військового експерта Майка Мартіна,
влучання ракет на території сусідніх з Україною держав
було неминучим. Водночас це може бути й приводом до подальшої ескалації.
Із самого початку війни обидві сторони - і Росія, і НАТО -
докладали всіх зусиль, аби конфлікт не виходив за межі України.
Заклики закритого неба були відкинуті,
ядерні погрози Росії так само.
Адже хоч війна в Україні і жахлива,
більш масштабний конфлікт - це повна катастрофа.
Цей останній інцидент - двоє загиблих громадян держави-члена НАТО -
тут уже обом сторонам складніше говорити про деескалацію
і стримування конфлікту в межах українських кордонів.
Аналітики єдні, що після удару по Польщі допомога Україні від західних партнерів
лише посилиться. Не виключають і більш радикальної реакції,
але вже за результатами розслідування.
Насправді, на мою думку, це призведе до більшої підтримки України
та збільшення готовності, можливо, надати Україні певну зброю,
яку Захід ще не надав, і до подальшого збільшення підтримки України в цьому конфлікті.
І це також може призвести до того, що Білорусь
може отримати застереження або навіть
і удар у відповідь по своїй території, якщо російські сили справді
випустили ракети з Білорусі по території НАТО.
Тим часом на тлі влучання ракети в Польщі збирається уже
сьоме засідання контактної групи з оборони України у форматі Рамштайн.
Реагуючи на інцидент у Польщі, президент Литви
закликав посилити протиповітряну оборону НАТО
на східних кордонах. А прем'єр Канади пообіцяв
більше підтримки українським збройним силам.